[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 173 qna
segment we are ready to uh to go
are you ready to go if you're looking
for more q and A's because we are going
to start dropping the number of Q and
A's
um by half
um we have our private q and A's monthly
that you can get access to at my patreon
and those are those feel different
because there's a much smaller number of
people
who are showing up live and so we can
actually engage with the chat and
respond to it so those are fun and
they're also long they're always two
hours and these are an hour or less
and speaking of an hour or less let's
get started let's do it because it's
been a little bit uh we've got actually
two questions from the Discord server
this week we always start with Discord
questions that the Discord server people
send over and we're going to do both of
them
yes we are awesome first question
Francine Shapiro was walking in the park
when she realized that eye movements
appear to decrease the negative emotion
associated with her own distressing
memories
leading to the practice of EMDR for PTSD
I did not know that history
is it possible that hunter-gatherers
regular scanning of their environments
for food or threat held to minimize an
obviously more traumatic world than the
one we currently live in
I want to know more about this this is
this is fascinating and I wonder if for
instance
um
you know one of the things that they say
is that if you're if you're feeling down
exercise definitely exercise and
I can't generalize this because I have
never been able interested in or able to
get interested in moving around a lot
inside like in the gym so for me when I
feel like I just gotta get out of my own
head I gotta get over myself whatever it
is I'll go for a bike ride or kayaking
or paddle boarding or
um even just a walk right
um and those things not a gym so much
not indoor environment but those things
um would be providing exactly the kinds
of fluctuating visual uh in
signals uh that is being invoked here
that apparently Francine Shapiro as the
founder of EMDR
um saw and I wonder if that's not at
least also a factor in if not perhaps
significantly a factor in the reason
that exercise at least Outdoors does
seem to help get people out of whatever
anxious or dark or depressive mood that
they're in
um
I I'm on board with that but I want to
put a slightly different uh
a slightly different perspective on this
the mind is a
a processor of information
and presumably it has evolved to process
information in a way that an ancestral
environment would result to the
computing power being dedicated to the
things which were most likely to provide
dividends either by increasing profits
or decreasing losses
when one's mind is not processing visual
information that processor is dedicated
to other things we talked in our book
about dreams for example dreams being
basically borrowing of the processors
including the visual processor or
scenario excuse me scenario building and
interpreting past events right both both
directions and time but all for the
purpose presumably of arming you for a
future right past events May tell you
that certain things can happen and you
see prepare for them future events that
you can foresee Loom large
so basically I want to argue for some
principle of
the Adaptive borrowing of perceptual
machinery for processing of
matters of opportunity or hazard
to the extent
for me
I can navigate our house in almost
complete darkness right the tiniest bit
of information a tiny bit of light
emerging from a door or a glint off of a
knob on the stove whatever it is is
enough for me to orient and walk around
that tells you is that walking around in
our house even when it's flooded with
light
I don't need to process all of that
right it's
processed at some level but it's not a
high level because I don't need it in
order to know where I am
so
by extension that means my mind is
actually free
to either imagine up cool stuff that
might be profitable but the
opportunities to imagine up new stuff
might pale in comparison to dwelling on
unrealized opportunities or dangers so
it may be that if you're prone to
dwelling on those things that an
environment that you know well does
nothing to fill your processor with
stuff that it needs to work on and
therefore leaves you idle to dwell on
exactly at the moment you feel like oh
I'm feeling anxious I'm feeling like the
outside world may be not safe so I'm
going to stay where I know I'm going to
stay in the familiar which may actually
exacerbate the problems exactly the
anxiety part of the problem whereas what
you should be seeking is novelty where
your brain actually has something that
it needs other needs or can think about
like oh there's that there's oh I
haven't been here before
interestingly just anecdotally I have on
my um
organizational software a regular thing
on a repeat uh periodicity of I don't
even know what it is five six days
um go somewhere new that's all it says
just go somewhere new and you know by
walk by Bike by kayak just like be go
somewhere you have not been before and I
don't know when I put that on there and
for how long it's been there but uh
every time it pops up I'm like oh yeah
no I should totally should uh because it
feel it feels healthy in every regard
yep feels healthy in every regard and of
course this hypothesis makes predictions
about what sorts of activities will be
most effective at banishing those
impulses to dwell on negative stuff
you know like uh for example trail
running
ought to be running on pavement right
because it requires more attention to
the second I were literally talking
about this this morning he you you don't
know you were already running your
patreon call this morning but Zach went
for a run this morning and uh began the
first quarter of a mile on the road
because we don't have a trail ride
outside our house and then was on trail
and then it was not a loop but a there
and back so the last quarter mile again
was not just on road but the same road
he'd been on but the opposite direction
um or no actually you did turn it into a
loop somehow didn't you
I didn't turn into loop I it was like
three and a half miles total but a
little bit at the end to get some extra
mileage was on the road as well but a
bunch of it was Trail anyway talk about
your experience
um the difference oh the different
experiences between the trail running
and the road running I don't know I
haven't really done trailer running
before uh
I don't know it was nice it distracted
me from thinking about
how unpleasant it is to run at some
level right um and so it was sort of
nice and when you're back on the road
it's your mind's very open so yeah so I
mean it's better for you yeah this is
separate from the the topic that we're
directly trying to respond to but
you know the trail running on trail is
better for you for a few physical
reasons like physiological reasons um
you know the ground is more forgiving on
your feet than um asphalt or or concrete
and uh also the inconsistencies the fact
that it's not just totally flat means
that you have to respond to the
environment you are in and so your body
is actually doing more and you're going
to get more in shape by actually being
responsive to
um even even a just mildly undulating
surface as opposed to one that is always
exactly the same so you know on a scale
from like treadbell to Road running to
trail running uh trail running is going
to be the one that you
um you know are going to have to be the
most conscious for
and you probably are not going to be
able to take in a complex analytical
lecture through your air pods while
you're trail running to the degree that
you could on the treadmill but you're
going to have a much more integrative
and more Health enhancing experience
yep
anyway I think we've gotten there
um but I would say
uh
a mind that is occupied with
novel stuff that has to be processed is
probably
immune to or close to immune to dwelling
on remote things and that our lives are
especially in light of it open lockdowns
and other stuff that have forced us not
only into indoor environments but forced
us into the same environment day after
day yeah that those things were
particularly likely to have the opposite
effect
indeed
second question from Discord this week
they say it's a question from the eighth
round of book club that they did which
is awesome they read a book called Deep
Simplicity by John Griffin not a book
that I know but I like the title deep
Simplicity question is
if life did evolve on other planets
would bipedal eyes forward structure be
optimal on those planets in general
would similar complex systems find
similar Solutions
and this is this is a topic about which
both you and I could go on about for a
very long time and we've we've answered
some version of this question uh before
um Let me let me make a first step and
we'll go back and forth a few times
um
you asked specifically the Discord
server asked specifically about both
bipedal and eyes forward structure which
is just so it's called frontation when
your eyes are both on the same plane
basically and the surface of your head
such that you can triangulate and get
binocular vision as opposed to having a
greater field of vision but it's harder
to perceive depth because for each of
your eyes you only have one eye on any
particular prize that you're looking at
whereas we have a lot behind our heads
that we can't see but what we can see is
almost entirely
perceivable with both of our eyes thus
we can track about about how far it is
and get a much better sense of position
and and speed as well
uh so would that you know would uh if if
we start from if eyes would frontation
uh just to say the idea to have
binocular vision be something uh that
evolved in some organisms yes
but you know if eyes
are photons going to be useful in uh to
sense your surrounding environment
almost certainly you know could life
evolve in a situation of total darkness
in which there are other ways to sense
things I guess maybe we don't know what
that would look like but so assuming a
world in which you have
um
you know a non-partly locked planet and
therefore there's night and day for
everyone on the planet and uh generally
some organisms are optimized for dark
some for night very occasionally for
crepuscular the the Dawn and dusk times
those organisms that need to perceive
distance quickly which is to say often
predators of other organisms that move
around will tend to end up having eyes
forward facing
bipedality is
is a bigger question because whereas
photons are likely to be in abundance
and free on just about any planet on
which life can evolve the advantage of
bipedality are much more specific to the
situation that we find ourselves in on
this particular planet with our
particular history of being first well
first sea dwelling then land dwelling
then tree dwelling primates and then
came back down to land so we you know
we're secondarily terrestrial but we
only emerge from the sea once but we
want to our primate ancestors were all
arboreal so we came down
and then some of our ancestors
presumably haven't come down we're still
moving around in all fours and then at
some point we we start to emerge
we start to emerge as bipedal organisms
why so is it so that we can carry things
is it so that we can seem higher over
the grassland Savannahs in which we were
mostly coming out of the trees in the
forests into
is it uh so you know there those are
those two of the two of the main
hypotheses for why we ended up going
bipedal and there were of course a
number of other Associated changes with
the bipedal gate
bipedality seems particular enough that
it's not at all clear to me that another
origin of even sentient you know highly
sentient conscious life would inherently
be bipedal on a different planet with
different considerations
that's a first pass
yeah I would I would answer this
similarly I think photons are free in
most of the circumstances that we would
expect to see life not all of them I I
think it's perfectly plausible that you
could evolve in a dark
uh situation and use something else but
um but I would expect you know the way I
would do this is I would say don't
imagine some other place imagine that
there are millions or billions of other
places where life has evolved and we see
bite Fidelity often right we see it more
than half the time maybe not
um not in Centurion creatures but you
know we have multiple
bipedal terrestrial creatures right the
birds we've got the birds we've got one
orange macropods uh kangaroos kangaroos
yep so the point is bipubality
bipedality Works in certain creatures we
have kangaroo rats we've got uh you know
there's a facultatively bipedal yeah but
my point is it shows up and you have
intermediates you know uh lagomorphs
rabbits but in all those cases it's from
a quadrupedal
um Source right so you've got
um in the biped and the bipedal
organisms that you've just named they're
all tetrapods they've all they've all
emerged from a deuterostome ancestor
which um
which has a which uh are bilaterally
symmetrical we have a left and a right
we mostly neatly
um you can draw a line and axis down our
middle and fold Us in half and we're
more or less please don't yeah don't try
this at home or anywhere else actually
um unless you're a mortician in which
case I guess you're allowed to but
probably not
um but I actually wrote about this in
the sea stars piece uh you know their
their thing echinoderms is radial
symmetry and our thing is bilateral
symmetry and bilateral symmetry is of
course not just a a thing of of
chordates which is vertebrates plus a
few other little things like tunicates
insects have bilateral symmetry but
um you know cephalopods squid and
octopuses don't have bilateral symmetry
and they're plenty smart they're plenty
sentient so uh bipedality what
I'm struggling over you know cephalopods
not having bilateral symmetry I'm you
know I'm not actually positive they do
well ammonites
they do
all right we're gonna wrestle this to a
proper conclusion at some point offline
and maybe but even turn to it but if the
question doesn't ask about
um
you know well what would be optimal also
is a little bit of a problem like what
is optimal on the planet there's no
answer to that well you know we are we
optimal are we the optimal form on this
planet well we have become the dominant
form on this planet but that doesn't
mean that our form is what allowed us to
become the dominant species on the
planet right well
there's they're components of it and
this comes up in in your discussion of
bipedality right we're always looking
for some answer like oh stood up to
carry things or whatever but I didn't
mention a third really stupid hypothesis
the anthropologists have oh good yeah
um we went bipedal um so that our backs
didn't get sunburned
because we lost our hair okay yeah I've
actually heard I've had an
anthropologist and you might be able to
imagine which one argue that in front of
a class to me wonderful yeah okay
um but I would say there's another
possibility that's a little bit harder
to wrestle to uh a testable
testable uh question
but that is
in order to become what we were our
manual dexterity had to become much
greater
that becomes possible at the point
you're not walking on your hands and so
is there some interplay be you know the
fact is it's a specialization move yeah
so we as bipeds don't have opposable
toes right all the other primates have
opposable toes therefore
the hands and feet are much more
equivalent to one another yeah they're
similar while not being identical you
know right they're not they're not even
close but but they do very they they can
do a lot more with their feet than we
can do with our feet yeah yeah um and so
in any case I don't you know
tooth whales are very intelligent it's
hard to imagine them ever doing to a
globe what we've done to it because they
in order to have flippers do not have
the dexterity they don't their fingers
aren't separate which means that their
ability to manipulate the world to test
hypotheses things like that is reduce
their ability to produce Tech you know
the path to a whale having the capacity
to do these things even if it had the
intelligence that would set it on that
path is a much more difficult road so
and I think um it's Shark Bay in
Australia uh some of the Dolphins which
are toothed whales have adopted I'm not
sure at Shark Bay but somewhere I've
adopted the habit of um mounting sponges
to their noses
um so that when they hunt sea urchins
they don't get jabbed by the urchin
poison interesting because I thought
that the explanation was the same one
that has people putting lampshades on
their heads at parties yes right yes but
that presumably has very little to do
with the urchins
probably unless the sea urchin said
something you know mean to them and
they're just drinking their their
sorrows away oh I suppose that's um not
very likely but
leave it in the realm of the possible
but in any case uh if you imagine
millions of planets with life that
reaches sentience which is certainly the
you know I think many of our expectation
about a universe this large is that it
would contain millions uh yes Millions
is even a low number for living planets
that would have attained sentients or
will
um but would you find bipedality on many
of them I feel certain you would find it
on many of them many of the creatures
among the sentient beings
I think it would be a frequent thing I
think uh visual orientation but I think
that begins again from the quadripedal
expectation right so if
the progression that we have here
life merges originates in the sea
uh life emerges from the sea a few times
in our lineage it emerges in uh in a
vertebrate form with uh a single you
know a single brain with a single line
of central nervous system down the back
and bilateral symmetry bilateral
symmetry such that upon coming out you
have to deal with all the new things
associated with gravity and different
refractive indices of Air versus water
all of this
um and that you know if if that's what
you're doing if you've got like a
quadrupedal form that is effectively
that is also in the case of Earth a
tetrapod that has emerged under land and
that's the lineage that becomes sentient
on either Planet would bipedality end up
being the sentient form in many of them
yeah but I don't but you know why not
radial symmetry as uh the thing that
becomes sentient why not
um aquatic creatures being the thing
that becomes sentient and you know in
neither of those cases do you expect
bipedality to be uh the form that the
sentient beings adopt well my guess is
there's a kind of very weak anthropic
principle that we can use here right the
fact that a bipedal visually oriented
creature attains sentience enough to
travel into space
um
means that that is at least one valid
path there
could a radially symmetrical creature
travel such a path maybe but what if
it's 500 times more difficult right then
the point is you would see it
occasionally but you wouldn't see very
regularly you'd be much more likely
especially if you effectively have
look you have
selection
exploring design space right
a quadrupedal platform is not the only
platform that can explore design space
in the way that the tetrapods have but
it is a very effective and repurposable
platform so you would expect to see many
such Explorations and the question is
would you expect to see in such an
exploration a bipedal lineage be more
likely to attain technological capacity
I think so so I don't I don't know that
you would and I guess I I feel like the
anthropic principle makes a
probabilistic error then that well this
is the one we've got therefore this is
the one that is more likely
um so it feels to me like just as
just as in the tetrapod lineage you have
um
invertebrates you have sort of a
relatively early split after the origin
of bone into rayfin fishes and lobefin
fishes and lobe pinfishes which includes
coelacans and lungfish and all the
tetrapods you have over time a reduction
of the number of digits and so some
extant let's say still living on the
planet members of that clade have like
eight
digits and then we get a reduction and
you know you get to like a horse with
one remaining digit right
um so there is of course room to say
okay well how like how many things is
the right number and over in radial
symmetry land just in the example that
we happen to know because this is where
we live among the sea stars among the
starfish you have a number of arms
ranging from five to fifty
so that same kind of Developmental
plasticity well in the case of sea stars
it seems to
usually be species level differences but
to some degree developmental plasticity
it seems like that could be
extraordinarily useful in a sentient
organism to you know if uh you know how
many times have you wanted more than two
of these to do what you're trying to do
and to be able to reach behind you and
you know in In Living in more more
spatial axes than we we do live in well
I want to I want to take issue with one
thing it's probably it's it's too subtle
to really pursue it but
the question of whether or not the
anthropic principle applied to such a
question is
statistically invalid again I said it's
a very weak form because we could be a
very unusual right sentient creature
right that's always possible it could be
the only one that is bipedal in the
whole universe because it was a very
difficult route and we took it and we
wouldn't know that because we haven't
seen any other examples however
let's say that an alien species
had a transporter and it transported
exactly one person at random off the
Earth
okay
what are the chances that that person
has a height that is somewhere near the
average
pretty high
what is the chances that that person's
height is exactly average
zero
so
there's a weak ability to infer a weak
but not non-existent zero no the chances
that their height is exactly equal
actually is zero nobody's height is
exactly that's not what I was responding
to that's not what you said
but the chances that what we look like
looks like nothing else in the universe
are low
but not zero
right not zero yeah sorry that's a true
responding a different different point
chances are not zero and if you picked
one person at random although they would
be average in exactly no way it's
probably not a single characteristic
that they're truly indistinguishable
from
the average
but the chances that you would you know
you'd be 50 50 on sex
right there is no average sex there are
two Sexes so you'd have information on
one and not the other
might be able to infer the other
but in every other regard you would have
information of a noisy kind about
intelligence you know what if you
selected somebody at random who was
severely mentally disabled right you
happen to pick the person that you know
in cognitive failure at the end of their
life not representative but the chances
that you would do reach such a person
are low so anyway there'd be a smatterer
I'm not sure what what we're setting up
here I'm not sure what I'm going to end
up having to respond to point is the
individual as representative of the
species is not a different puzzle than
our version of sentience evolving in a
I don't think that's I don't agree with
that
um I don't I don't again I don't think
that it's zero because the universe does
have some universal laws
right but even
and I would have to go back and look at
the research I was doing when I was
working on science fiction but um you
know even the type of star
um that the planet that the life has
evolved in is around and therefore uh
the the frequencies the the you know be
the abundance the temperature range uh
the
you know is is it carbon-based life
right or is it silicon based life like
they're just so many things that render
life here versus life elsewhere in the
universe much more different potentially
than one individual versus another
individual from the same species on the
same instantiation of the evolution of
sentient life on this planet
um no I think I think that that is
actually looking at it the wrong way
okay how because
yes there are many differences could be
carbon could be silicon don't know which
one would be more common but it's not an
infinite diversity that on which you
could build a platform of life that
would look like Earth life so the
ability to work backwards why does it
have to look like Earth life
it doesn't but this is like and so if if
we're constrained to it looks like Earth
life then that seems like a cheat
no
you know is it possible to have
life in a state of
plasma
right where you do not have elements
having coalesced for example probably
not
am I ruling it out do I think I know
enough no but my point is we do know
that you can get life in a universe that
is you know rich with chemical elements
and sufficiently cool and all of that we
know you can get it on a planet that
isn't tidally locked uh we don't know
for sure what happens if you bake the
hell out of one side of a planet and
leave the other in total darkness that's
an interesting thought experiment but
it's we do know that on a planet that
rotates and provides a balance you you
do get certain forms evolving so anyway
all I'm saying is that
the
amount of information that a single
individual provides about the species
Homo sapiens is considerable but there
you could imagine many places where
extrapolating from a single individual
would lead you into a cul-de-sac so it's
low quality information but it's
significant information
I'm inferring
that in a universe full of different
evolutions of life in which some of
those Evolutions produce something
sentient that a single individual has
the same characteristic an evolution of
Life what characteristic that it tells
you some things about how life is the
same character so a single individual
from a species
of sentient life on some other planet
should similarly provide an indication
albeit imperfect of what the whole
species is like right and the way that
that is most useful is that we can say
what are the chances that we are an
average platform for sentience
but that's to me that's that's a leap
there so individuals representing
species imperfectly yes here elsewhere
yes therefore an example here uh you can
use to infer what it likely looks like
there I am not as compelled well again
I'm I'm projecting onto a universe of
examples that we will never see yeah
unfortunately no I don't think
unfortunately the question is you don't
want to see them no oh
yes I very much want to see them uh
immediately if possible and I have
questions
um
for them so hopefully do they hopefully
and no doubt they would but all my only
point is the chances that our path to uh
sentience was particularly convoluted or
low the chances that it's something like
the average path is relatively High yes
I just don't there's
many
I mean you you know this represents
anyone so
um you know if every even if every step
if every step there were a thousand
possibilities
and 500 of those are kind of near the
middle and even I mean let's just like
even if it's just a hundred that are
like more likely than not and every
single time we went with one of those
middle hundred that's still so like you
take that one or that one and now you're
like no no you just go so far again I
think I think the logic is incorrect
work this way and I get it right I mean
I so I have not yet heard the counter
argument
okay can we rule out
sentient plants
no we can't no are am I expecting them
no no I'm really not no I'm so
disappointed in this question well I
know but but my point is is it's safe to
rule out essentially the plants no nope
on the other hand uh would I be right to
be surprised as I ran into them
elsewhere in the universe I would be
right to be surprised because there are
logical reasons to say that that
actually was a branch not particularly
likely to generate sentience but the
original question which also
incidentally didn't talk about sentience
but like we've turned we've moved into a
sentence question specifically mentions
two characteristics
frontation like binocular vision and
bipedality yep and in my initial foray
into answering it I did separate those
and said well you know given you know
yes it's possible it could be deep sea
it could be totally locked you could
like you know whatever maybe no photons
but given the ubiquity and freedness of
photons probably photons in which case
frontation yes almost very often I won't
say almost certainly but very often
whereas by pedality
um has a lot more contingencies that
happen before you end up having that be
a useful form yep I I agree I agree with
your hierarchy right I think I mean this
is like you know like this is this is
one of the things that I used to do in
my vertebrate Evolution programs like my
final big like it's like okay I've got
12 characteristics that have evolved on
this planet in a rerun from history
we're starting at 500 million years ago
I want you to Prior like you tell me and
you know use everything at your disposal
to argue for your K argue your case
which one of these things like the the
likelihood that each one of these things
would actually re-evolve in a re-running
of history from a starting point 500
million years ago like base base
vertebrate right and it included
everything from lungs and Feathers to
written language written language
language is an easy one it's always last
right um in on on this list but you know
how how do you prioritize things that in
this running of History are contingent
on one another right but aren't
necessarily contingent on one another
and it could have easily happened
um separately like I mean I think it's a
super fun game but I don't I don't think
given that there is a difference you
know even just between like binocular
vision frontation and bipedality
I'm I can't imagine why we imagine
um that the sentient aliens out there on
average kind of look like us
well I'm not saying that they do I'm
saying that you can infer something
about the potential of different
Pathways and the ability to you know for
you and me to look at things like plants
and say uh you know we don't really
expect uh
highly mobile photosynthetic animals
because it doesn't work and we don't
really expect plants to develop
sentients because it doesn't pay
uh yeah what they're doing for them
right what problem was it solving and if
I did that over a thousand different
questions would I expect to be wrong
some fraction of the time yes but I
would expect to be well above random at
the ability to say that's gonna you know
um
birds are going to have a despite
bipedality birds are going to have a
hard time developing technology because
their wings don't lend themselves to
become uh very dexterous in the
manipulation of objects like like
flippers right but on a different planet
perhaps uh the uh early equivalent of
land vertebrates have three pairs of
legs instead of two and then they get to
be the you know like the the Angels
right which have somehow three pairs of
appendages arms and wings and legs right
so maybe maybe maybe on a different
planet birds do become the tool users
because they're actually working with an
additional set of Limbs that is
possibility nothing in um in anything
that I have imagined that says oh well
that now that wouldn't happen like why
not why why two sets instead of three no
no insects are doing it I don't
necessarily see any reason to expect two
sets versus three because for one thing
we've seen an even more successful
radiation that has three sets so we know
that radiations with three sets can
explore a large amount of design space
and it you know it just so happens to be
uh arthropods who had some other uh
pieces of the deck stacked against their
sentience
um you know exoskeletons and things that
probably do not uh properly fit with
extremely long life spans and things
like that I wonder about complete
metamorphosis as well I wonder if if a
complete reconfiguring of all of your
body tissues as you become an adult
doesn't effectively limit the value of a
long childhood yeah it means that the
developmental pattern is unlikely to
discover something in which you have a
second pattern a second mode of
inheritance things like that yeah anyway
I just don't think that
as somebody has spent a lot of time
thinking about design space and how
selection explores it
it's an impossibly complex puzzle that
is much less complex than a completely
free canvas and it's not a completely
free canvas but I'm not um
I think we have both thought about
things related to this from actually
surprisingly different
viewpoints from from from standing in
different places and I am I am not
compelled by what I hear as your
argument that uh
because each of these decisions
each of these things that ended up
evolving happened here and there were
reasons that they did and that the other
the other choices choices of the wrong
language here but the other thing is
that that evolved long since disappeared
that is very particular as you know not
just to the particular space and time in
which it happened but the long history
on which it was building
and the just the number of
you know lungs seem inevitable
you know are we running in our running
of History
lungs evolved
um
lungs evolved and were kind of in use
um before the thing that for a long time
we thought they evolved from the swim
bladders of acting up of rayfin fishes
like it looks to us like well they've
been in the water forever and so you
know we must have you know we must have
just co-opted that it's like no somehow
there were lungs already like nascent in
these water breathing Gill having
organisms
super surprising what like we don't as
far as I know I haven't looked at the
literature in a few years but like we
don't I really have a good idea of what
that was about like why that was there
why that was retained for a long time
without having obvious functionality and
then uh and then sort of bursts into two
very different things that are
homologous one another they're like the
same organ but doing very different
objects doing very different functions
on land and water
given how many of those stories we know
about
this planet
there have to be just as many stories on
any other planet where life where
complex life has evolved believe me I
have no doubt that every evolution of
life would be completely surprising one
thing after another but there would also
be many many patterns which you would
get used to seeing repeatedly and I
would just point to another example a I
want to put a principle on the table
here
the principle is that once you have some
clade of creatures exploring design
space with some adaptation that it
reduces the chances of a second clade
discovering that thing because that
second clade will have a very hard time
competing with the first clade that has
an advantage not between planets no I'm
not there yet
my point would be let's take uh image
forming eyes
of which we have three examples on Earth
right we have the vertebrate example we
have the cephalopod example and we have
the insect example are you sure that
cephalopods and yeah yeah
separate separate Evolution separate
Evolutions three image forming eyes
which function very much similarly We
Now understand there are some advantages
to the cephalopod I the vertebrate eye
is inverted and has a blind spot that is
a defect but nonetheless the point is
how the thing works is
shockingly similar in spite of the fact
that you had clearly two of those three
being explored by a adaptive evolution
in a world that already had one
so
my my point is image forming eyes are so
useful
but it had one but it wasn't that one
wasn't available like the early
vertebrates didn't have access to a
cephalopodi right and uh
they the question is why in that world
were there niches sufficiently different
that the fact that some
Glade was already exploring with image
forming eyes did not mean that it was
simply going to out-compete any
vertebrate ancestor that developed an
eye for example so anyway my point is
the fact of selection repeating itself
with both
convergent evolution and parallelisms is
um
such a common pattern and happens
with such regularity and surprising
convergence on detail that it speaks to
a
constrained design space okay I I think
I know where we're disagreeing then okay
um because on eyes and even on
frontation which is a is which is a more
precise version of eyes and what you can
do with them
uh I think we're in agreement
it's fascinating that they pick these
two examples for this question right
with regard to bipedality
the the utility of bipedality is so
contingent not just on the landscape in
which you move but also the bow plan on
which you are evolving from development
from which you were evolving and there
are a number of of bowel plans that
organisms can evolve from that are
highly functional and that could still
allow them to manipulate tools and be
social and all of these things and there
are also a lot of uh media in which uh
sentient organisms might be moving
around their landscape where bipedality
would not necessarily be the right thing
so
um I you know you and I do not disagree
about the you know the power of
convergence the power of selection the
power of convergence uh I think we are
disagreeing at actually fairly trivial
level about you know because the part of
this that I've spent a very lot of time
talking thinking about is what kinds of
things would actually always happen
every single time and therefore you have
to put them right up at the top of the
list even if they don't seem important
to you yeah because they would just
always happen no matter what now in my
you know in the exam in the stakehold
exam I would always give to my students
it was a re-running of life on Earth
yeah and so things I do think that
things are potentially quite different
on other planets
um but there are other things that
wouldn't necessarily evolve and so you
know to some degree this may be
uninteresting to us but seem really
interesting to other people where if I
say well feathers might not evolve yeah
but flight well
flight will evolve right you know
on a planet with an atmosphere where
life is evolving where you know they're
you know where therefore there was
enough like resistance in the air that
flight could work flight will evolve but
it isn't necessarily something that we
might recognize as feathers right right
oh yeah totally totally agree and I
totally agree that the frontation of the
eyes is much more likely to be seen as a
regular pattern among sentient creatures
than bipedality bipedality seems much
more arbitrary and in fact bipedality is
kind of a bad bow plan as it is right
yeah we're not doing it very well it's
first birds are birds are rocking it
yeah that's brought with hazards
um and so it may be that that's actually
a hint about what it is that what else
we were you know our dexterity with our
hands was worth the cost of becoming a
quadruped that stood up on two legs and
dealt with the problem well at least our
backs aren't burned I mean we do have
that going for us right
um
anyway I I think we've got oh um
navigating through shallow Waters is
another POS is another thing that is
proposed for um so like aquatic ape the
smart version of The Aquatic ape
hypothesis for why we went bipedal that
you have for instance baboons in the
okavango delta in Botswana
um
sometimes action with babies on their on
their tummies as the mothers swim
between Islands during the flooded
season actually the babies will drown
like it's crazy but this is um Cheney
and safe Earth doing their amazing work
who've reported like they actually do
this like somehow they forget that the
baby can't breathe when it's underwater
so you know walking upright allows you
to go through deeper water and
potentially not drown your baby for
instance
or that was fun yeah all right
um let's see uh that was like most of
the time we have so we're gonna get to
we're gonna get through some questions
it was awesome in my opinion yeah that
was fun okay
um will you guys be doing Unity 2024
have you considered
uh rkj I'm thinking they mean RJ r f
wait no page hey what's rkj
I'm gonna assume you mean RFK Jr yeah
yeah arcade jail maybe it's Robert candy
Jr that's what that means okay I'm gonna
start over will you guys be doing Unity
201 I'm going to start over third time
take three will you guys be doing Unity
2024 have you considered Kennedy Vivek
and Dave Smith for a 24 year run love
you guys
uh I haven't considered that exact
grouping but yeah everything's on the
table we have uh the duopoly stepping up
to deliver us a rerun of one of the
great electoral horrors of our lifetime
and any other no one thought that was
fun no it wasn't fun it's not a good
idea that they do it again I do think
that um the duopoly let's put it this
way no one's smarter about being stupid
than the duopoly and the idea that it
could deliver us that same insane
matchup with so much more even at stake
at this point in history will not
surprised me in the least
um
and the question really is
uh are
the
disaffected folks
who so frequently are fed up and do not
vote because they're sick of losing do
they wake up and realize that they have
the power to turn this entire story on
its head if they will just get over the
uh
reasonable sounding but flawed logic
that has them sidelining themselves for
elections if so there's all sorts of
stuff to be done and if not we're cooked
so get used to it
anyway I'm talking to you disaffected
people you gotta vote even if you're
voting for something that can't win
Brett saidkowski tweet is frustrating I
worry your model is off Carl friston
Joshua Bach Paul Cristiano Conor Leahy
are great in rights
I don't know anything about this
um
Kowski and had any discussion in which
he
proposed a scenario
or
AI
ordering up some viruses that are highly
contagious so they get spread around the
globe with barely anybody noticing and
they cause the person who's had the
virus to suddenly become a slave-like
and devoted to the AI upon the playing
of a certain tone or some such thing
the degree
to which that scenario reveals an
evolutionarily undisciplined mind is
incredible
I am not arguing that we do not have to
worry about malevolent AI or misaligned
AI
not arguing that what I'm arguing is
that at the point that udkowski does not
know that he is spouting biological
nonsense
that he may indeed be trying to alert us
to a real danger that is immediate and
that we must respond to but that he is
doing harm to that cause by being
undisciplined in this way that is
alarming so I don't want us to underrate
the danger of misalignment plus
malevolence or if that's two kinds of
misalignments so be it
what I want is the folks who don't get
the biological part of it to recognize
it and say we don't know what exactly an
AGI could order up from one of the
places that you can
order biologically sequenced stuff right
the idea that it is going to produce
um
novel biota that is going to embarrass
natural selection right this is a dead
end it's a dead end when people have
tried it before it's going to be a dead
end if the AGI tries it the AI is
constrained to the same biological logic
that creatures are now
I'm not arguing there's no Hazard there
I'm arguing that the one that yodkowski
chose to throw off as if here is one of
an infinite number of possibilities that
could happen if you say here's one of an
infinite number of possibilities that
could happen
the thing you say next damn well better
be something that could happen right
just make it plausible it doesn't have
to be so elaborate that you don't have
to get an A in the class you just have
to demonstrate that something fits in
that spot and so anyway
um
that's pretty much the end of my rant
don't just invent nonsense and imagine
that because biology looks chaotic to
you that anything can happen because it
can't
okay a couple more AI questions while
you're on the topic okay
Eric Weinstein often talks about the
twin nuclei problem could AI be the
third member of the Trinity could a
sentient AI be able to then destroy life
and then recreate it in its image
I just don't know enough about twin
nuclei problem to to go there at all
well technically I promise Eric's
description for unlocking the atomic
nucleus
with nuclear Tech and the biological
nucleus with insight into DNA oh okay um
it's a certainly a very uh
clever insightful
way of looking at it and yes this is the
moment at which humans become so
thoroughly in charge of our own fate
that it changes everything from a past
in which a population could make a dumb
error and go extinct and not threaten
the whole human project right so that's
the era we live in and it's a good
description yes this did you just say
that's the error we live in
that's not what I said well it may be
what I said it's not when I sent the
messages to the muscles that's not what
I intended to say
um
but yeah AGI I don't know that it's a
you know unfortunately for The Branding
it's not a nucleus so you know we're
gonna have to stretch to fit it into
that rubric in order that it's still uh
linguistically efficient and clever
um but from every other perspective yeah
this is this is another place where we
have invited a whole new level of Hazard
to the human Project without sufficient
preparedness for our now Godlike
capacity
um and
the
you know I
I'm less worried that the AI is going to
decide hey this is a gorgeous planet and
it can be ours if we can get rid of life
so let's do it I not saying it's
impossible but I don't find that
especially likely
but I don't think you need that in order
to see the other hazards so so one more
AI question and I just I want to get
through a few of these since we have to
go sooner we only we barely began to get
into the questions here on topic of AI
maybe it could be possible to Institute
a stenographic key in all AI generated
material that when analyzed could
identify its sources AI generated
thoughts question mark the problem with
all such answers is they can be
jailbroken and the anyone can Jailbreak
it it's going to be yeah right exactly
and you know we've already seen this
it's Child's Play to get the thing to
find its way out and in fact
I'm unfamiliar with the particulars of
the experiment in fact I think utkowski
may not have shared them
but there's some
uh story circulating in uh AI x-risk
communities about
umkowski demonstrating that he could
talk a human into letting an AI out of
its prison
you know that he could basically play on
human compassion to get a person to do
the AIS bidding to get it out of the
sandbox so
um
I think that is a matter of
they already let the damn horses out of
the barn and
to the extent that what you do is you
constrain ai's
to confess who generated what then you
provide an advantage to any AI that
escapes and shackle the others so I
don't think the actual solution is down
that road I do think there are solutions
to this problem
not perfect ones
um but anyway I I have a
I have tried to get the attention of
some folks who
have prominence in this community about
Solutions of a more biological nature
that I think are worth thinking about
but that's about all I want to say
okay
uh Scott Adams made a hoax list
regarding Trump is there a list of lies
about covid and current mainstream
status of the truth like Lab Lake
I don't know of when
I did a
this isn't it but I have a number of
two and a half months ago February 28th
my Natural Selections piece was
apparently where the bad guys or don't
ask permission to speak and I have
basically a bulleted list of things uh
in here
that we said during the pandemic I
didn't ex I didn't expect this to hit so
big as it did it it's so it's so people
really liked this and I was not trying
to be thorough I was almost off the top
of my head like what else did we say and
where were we wrong were we right
um but this is
um and at least a start on a list of
things uh in that
we were saying that we're opposite of
what the mainstream narrative was saying
and we have been Vindicated
um by if even if not yet in the public
eye
in some cases clearly by the science and
the empirical evidence
but um I don't know of such a resource
Zach if you could give me my screen back
so I could go back to the question
um
yeah current mainstream satisfaction I
don't I mean I wish there was such a
resource but it would be a devil to
maintain it would be you know somewhat
simple to create but then to maintain it
would be tough so what exactly I didn't
see Scott Adams list of whatever it was
I don't know it was made a hoax list
regarding Trump is what it says so these
are hoaxes that were perpetrated about
Trump sounds like it injecting yourself
with bleach stuff like that yeah is
there a list of lies about covet and
current mainstream status of the truth
like loud Lake
um and you know earlier you know
sometime between uh three years ago and
now I occasionally got sent
um
a little like video amalgams of um here
are things that uh you know Biden and
Saki when she was the press secretary
and fauci said and you know over and
over and over again now we're being told
no one ever said that right oh vaccines
stop transmission oh right
um so there I've seen little bits of
these but um I've never seen it collated
in one place
yeah I actually think it would be a good
idea and I'm wondering if there's not a
way uh
to crowd Source it right you know
something proposes here realize that
we're told uh provide a source and then
provide a modern source that shows the
delta
anyway I think I think it would be
worthwhile because this is the kind of
thing it's
I don't know I was looking at a um a
video compilation of uh places where the
unvaccinated were being demonized and
threatened recently and I was shocked
even though it was only
a couple years back at how a vivid and
aggressive and uh
nasty these claims were and so anyway
the point is time is moving so quickly
now that it's hard to even remember what
that era was like even though it was
effectively yesterday so I do think such
a list would be useful
my mother was recently scolded by a
junko while pruning blackberries in her
garden turns out they're nesting at the
base of a big ceramic planter we see and
hear Hungry mouths
yeah it's the time of year for uh
mama and daddy Birds to scold the people
who stray too close to their nests
that's cool
is there a correlation between
pathologies associated with
consanguinity and there and that is to
say inbreeding mating between close
relatives and the repression of
homosexuality and different that is to
say non-modern societies
I never thought to put those two things
next to each other before and I don't
nothing kind I'm not sure I understand
the question
is there a correlation between
pathologies associated with
consanguinity and the repression of
homosexuality I
I don't think so but I'm gonna have to
think through it because I don't think
so either never heard that better yeah
interrelated
just a few questions that I at least
have no really no ability to respond to
what do you think about the hepatitis C
medication I have no idea don't know
yeah
uh are you familiar with organ chips
they sound promising for personal drug
testing
and the link that
they give
so hard to get links off of this uh is
that Harvard slash technology slash
human organs on chips
so the word organ is throwing me yeah if
they're talking about these chips in
which you can effectively expose an
array of something to
um
some substrate and see which quadrants
light up
yeah I've seen Technologies like that
and I don't see in principle why there's
any reason you couldn't build one that
would tell you whether a particular
person was compatible with a particular
drug
so in principle that sounds reasonable
mimicking human organs in vitro enabling
faster better and cheaper drug
development insights into human health
oh
um ah that's slightly different yeah
microfluidic devices lined with living
human cells for drug development disease
modeling and personalized medicine I've
never heard of this before
um
I think I know what I think
I would say this is effectively like a
sophisticated computer model
and what I don't want to see is somebody
decide that what happens on the chip is
what will happen in the living organism
I would want this to accelerate the
process by which we figure out what
might not be safe yeah and allow us to
Target experiments more accurately yes
don't mistake the chip for the in Vivo
experience of what it is but um if
if the arrogance can be kept at Bay and
an understanding of both trade-offs and
evolution be persistent throughout the
research there's potential here yep sure
let's see
all right let's get a couple more before
we go
um
okay two more
how does one balance a love of dogs
and the outdoors with a rational fear of
ticks
um
you know we don't we are lucky to live
in a place without much in the wave
ticks uh
um
and I I have wondered this it's been a
long time since you or I were on the
East Coast lived on the East Coast or
Midwest
um
I mean it's gonna it's gonna depend on
your particular situation your
particular environment you know where
the ticks are how common they are
whether or not they are seasonal whether
or not they have circadian Cycles uh you
know whether or not they really don't
get into
um skin if you are well sealed you know
if your clothes are well sealed all that
you know the ectoparasites are not just
a just a single thing it's like oh it
just you know in order to avoid ticks
you must do X it's going to be different
depending on the particular situation
but
um you know my biases you've figured out
of course you get outside and you get
your dog outside but uh
dogs of course are not going to be well
suited to being um
have it explained to them how to avoid
the ticks in your area yeah I would say
personally there's probably some best
approach with clothing you know it might
be that a brimmed hat keeps them
off to some extent and well are they
falling on you out of trees and things
um keeping them off your dog is the
second thing it's of course in some
sense
less important dogs being shorter lived
and not people but it's still important
um
yeah and you got to spend a long time
checking both you and your dog when you
come in that's what I was going to say
is that in addition to Preparing well
for going outside and knowing whether or
not you're in a Ticky location or a
Ticky moment in the year or both
vigilance when you get back and a
thorough check to make sure that you in
particular don't have something Brewing
on your scalp or wherever is going to be
key
um and the dog will love it you go
through the entire dog looking for ticks
totally free scritches uh the dog will
love it the ticks will not that's okay
well in fact I would say it's good the
only good tick is a nervous tick
did you send in this question
no I did not but thank you to whoever
did thanks Isabella great
okay final question
I don't know if I'm pronouncing this
person's name correctly but I think most
viewers and listeners will recognize who
we are talking about what are your
thoughts on Elon musk's hire for the
Twitter CEO Linda yaccarino
yeah oh boy
um a couple things to say here
one by the Numbers this is a terrible
Choice from the point of view of
Twitter's well-being I think and
from the point of view of Twitter's
credibility in the eyes of those of us
like me who have championed this as a
potentially important uh step in the
direction of a free speech platform that
uh you know zero is a special number is
an important concept and this seemed
like a departure from zero that said
I do think that the right approach is to
give
Linda ocarino
the ability to surprise us I'm ready to
be surprised I am most concerned about
her association with wef which is of
course a huge red flag for many of us
um I'm also concerned
about her
overt stance on covid measures
I will say I did it happens that we know
somebody who knows her somebody who has
worked at NBC still works at NBC and is
a prominent coveted dissident
who retained their job
through the pandemic in spite of being a
prominent coveted activist in fact and
that that is apparently not the only
story from an inside NBC where people
who departed from the conventional
wisdom survived there in a way that
people did not survive in other similar
locations so there's a possibility
that uh Linda yaccarino is
mercenary
but behind the scenes has
[Music]
um
protected people who stood up I don't
know but that is at least a possibility
I don't know what you do about the world
economic Forum connection that is such a
toxic organization that I don't know how
you would ever know that somebody was
free of it and if they're not free of it
I don't know what happens when they come
through the door of Twitter in this
position of CEO that seems very
dangerous but nonetheless again I do
think uh
being open to being pleasantly surprised
is is the right approach but I won't be
surprised if this goes bad quickly and
she's out and it gets
uh changed somebody else gets put in
that role well I haven't done much
looking but I did just look at her
timeline on Twitter because if she's
going to be the next CEO of Twitter her
timeline and Twitter would seem to be
um something to look at and I might have
thought that it would have a lot of new
things since she became aware of what um
what her new job was going to be but I
can't say I'm impressed
Zack of you would show
this is not it seems to be entirely
unrepresentative piece this is from you
know a few days ago this is a retweet
from you know peacock which I guess is
about NBC getting all my Kentucky Derby
inspo from these ladies with pictures of
women in stupid hats at the Kentucky
Derby and just looking like the
apparently the Real Housewives of Orange
County
uh some of these outfits could have
worked at the Met Gala she says so to me
this does not look like a serious human
being
maybe this is just her you know the one
thing that she does for fun she likes
hats she likes to think about fashion I
don't know
um but it feels to me like we are in a
world of
um God such regressive
gender roles like
how is it that we simultaneously have
Dylan Mulvaney parading around
pretending to be a woman and
um half the country is going like yeah
you go girl and the new CEO of what's
supposed to be like
the Free Speech platform but I'm not
seeing it
um who's tweeting these ridiculous
regressive stupid pictures
um from you know she also has tweeted
like it looks like she actually cares
about the Kentucky Derby and there was a
the winner this year was a 38-1 odds
against cool interesting right but
the hat and fashion garbage is absurd
and uh you know if she comes in and one
of the first things she does for
instance and you know I've said it
before but you know is is takes off the
censorship on substack that Twitter is
now engaging in and no one is admitting
or talking about but it's just patently
clear uh that you can no longer
basically shut people to a sub stack
through Twitter unless they are really
really driven to do so because they
don't show up as as good embedded
um they don't embed anymore right
um
I I don't know why we're talking about
as a free speech platform at the moment
frankly because it looks Petty and um
and ridiculous and if the new CEO is
more interested in stupid hats than in
um not engaging in censorship I
I'm not impressed
yep well uh I
can't imagine that this was done
without there was a great deal
considerable thought put into
considerable thought which makes the
Paradox never surprised I hope we are
surprised absolutely and I also just
have to say
it is very easy for those of us on the
outside not to understand the full
dimensionality of the problem of doing
what Elon appears to be trying to do and
so the point is if we're looking at four
trade-offs and he's looking at 20. sure
right we may not understand why this
move made sense I find it hard to
imagine that anything in that basket of
things that we business normies can't
into it
overcomes an active connection with the
world economic Forum are just hard to
imagine but who knows what we don't know
who knows what we don't know I hope we
find out yep
all right we'll be back again next week
uh before then Brett's got a
conversation happening on patreon
tomorrow consider joining him there you
can get access to the Discord server and
uh and talk about all sorts of things
including
um future questions you'd like to see us
address as we did at the top of this
hour on the Discord server at either of
our patreons
and um just in general there's a lot of
places to find us go looking do
subscribe like share any content that
you see that you think is share worthy
and until we see you next time because
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
foreign
[Music]